I mean like those unfettered marijuana
sales in New York City right now you
can't walk down the street without
smelling it like every Bodega has
unregulated marijuana sales you don't
have any idea what is being purchased or
what is being sold you don't have to
show ID there's absolutely no regulation
and the city is trying to shut it down
now and be like no we're only going to
give weed licenses to people who were
formally incarcerated or you know on on
drug charges but it's been like over a
year you can't you can't tell the
bodegas they have to stop selling loose
pre-rolled joints now they're not going
to
um and it's it's unregulated it's
unfettered and it's not a good thing
yeah